hmm milk not a paid ad milk the stuff of
life my kid always tells me don't drink
milk because she's a vegan and you know
not your mu not your mom not your milk
that's what she says but as a big fat
adult baby milk man milk still only what
ago okay so welcome it's motivation
number two the sequel which means it may
not be as good as the original
what are we talking about today
I got a facebook life thing I'm gonna do
in about ten minutes right here
but for flash my episode the flash that
I directed airs today and also my movie
yoga hosers comes out on iTunes today
and comes out on blu-ray and DVD I think
if you want a signed version that go to
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash they
got it for you signed by a big fat turd
who made it this big fat turd okay
speaking of fat though Before we jump
into what's happening later it's
motivation meant to be quick and
motivation [ __ ] like that facing fear
that's the important part you ever want
to do something with with your life you
got a face you fear overcome your fear
because there's a natural tendency to
not want to try anything new to not want
to try anything I'm trying to be thin
never be thin to not try you know to the
new is scary and it's trepidatious and
stuff like that the fear as they told us
in dude fears the mind killer which
they're remaking dune man legendary
picked up the rights to doing a redo
dune now it's becoming a little bit that
mountain Batman anyway back to some
motivation fear being the big mind
killer man this is what you always got
to remember it's you just face it you
got to try to face it you know we can't
face the big fears like death and [ __ ]
one day you face that and that's that
think life is all about building up
enough courage to face death which is
[ __ ] terrifying to those of us who
don't know what's on the
sigh I've heard from plenty people who
think they know it's on the other side
nobody knows kids so that should be
something be afraid of and used to spend
your whole life building up enough
courage to have a good death man face
that death with like you know what I did
it and then dropped it don't sit there
and be like why didn't I do my
accomplish my dreams when you die you
want to be able to be like this guy go
like can't believe we made the walrus
movie move and then drop dead hopefully
yours after the walrus movie in any of
that fear will hold you back from
anything so one of my biggest fears I'm
a heavy guy always have been
so taking off my shirt in public
suddenly everybody's like oh no oh no
that's right man in order to face the
fear do it in baby steps I'm one of my
biggest one is just is just like doing a
simple thing that most people take for
granted you go to the beach take your
shirt off you go to locker room you take
your shirt off and [ __ ] like that for me
that's [ __ ] terrifying that's scarier
than facing down a gun maybe that's
scary I don't know I've never faced down
a gun but I've also never taken off my
[ __ ] shirt in public so I've seen
some people asked me from time to time
there's a picture of a dude
topless dude on the internet a bear dude
like with a leather cap on I think that
somebody put my head on the legs that
you [ __ ] wish it was me man I do
who's got what look like muscles under
their mid pecs if you will I know pecs
here son so even in gym when I was kid
wait till everyone left the locker room
and then change or go to the bathroom
stall change or just skip gym or do gym
in my [ __ ] school clothes so you know
taking off shirt big not big deal for
most people big deal for me if you're
gonna stay here to tell people face
their fears [ __ ] I'm gonna face my fear
so I'm not gonna take my shirt off and
[ __ ] like rub one out and show you
all that stuff but baby steps right [ __ ]
it starts slow so let's list let's do
this as much again you ain't getting a
nipple work or anything like that that's
can you imagine that's like one of my
biggest fears in the world is just doing
what I just did right there my heart's
racing
I'm ready to [ __ ] [ __ ] myself but
boom it's over it's done I did it took
my [ __ ] man tits my hairy man
boobs my moobs if you will out on the
internet and somebody will I'm sure
grafted dick in my mouth or milk
spurting from a big fat boobs or
whatever but that's that's how you face
fear
Oh God so there you go folks today's
motivation face your fear now I'm not
saying everyone go out and take your
clothes off public clearly that's not
the message the message though has a lot
to do with you know whatever your [ __ ]
private thing it's little fear is unless
your fear is like I fear committing mass
extinction go out in public and shooting
people I'm not talking to you I'm
talking about face your fears and tilt
it down there you go face your fears
that don't let it hurt you not other
people remember don't [ __ ] hurt other
people motional II physically anything
like that don't be a dick
there it is so stick around if you want
to I moved back in a few minutes to do a
live chat for flash but that's today's
motivation man go out and take your
shirt off on the internet or whatever
metaphorically that is for you
I feel free tomorrow dick out Kevin
there's the biggest [ __ ] fear right
there that will remain hidden like
Tutankhamun for [ __ ] centuries only
to be dug up later on by some hapless
fool from Britain I think if I remember
my history cracker King Tut born and
moved to bet my only King Tut history
comes from Steve Martin song so I should
stop it right there
that's today's motivation stick around a
few minutes doing a flash live chat man
talking all about will [ __ ] seamount
reverse-flash son with a backwards
Jersey Smith backwards ah
Quigley Jim okay so there it is folks
thanks for hanging out and seen a little
bit when we do the flash live chat show
you moobs